[Applause]  leading the way with 22 for washington  fade away on the baseline make it 24 for  kuzma well that was the design play  and the intention was to get it to kooza  because  [Music]  now it's about to stop  ground rising to its feet  talked about the atmosphere we had here  on monday  [Music]  shot clock at five dinwiddie  no good harris the rebound maxie is  ahead of everybody but tobias can't get  it to him oh my goodness  embiid gets it back thought we might  have lost it joel  no whistle are you kidding me  kuzma  with the block and the ball  and joel and beat called for the foul  he drives here after he finally secures  the ball on the wing right here  gets it and now he is going  it looks like he just loses it on the  rubber  framing of the backboard on the way up  how unfortunate time out on the floor  6.2 to go  [Applause]